Minute. Tell everybody else they should be seeking partnership to.
That's the flip side of what this creator was talking about.
So go back and watch the original video.
It's a stitch of a stitch,
but it's about this whole four beef movement,
which, if you've never heard it,
is a movement of women who are basically not participating in dating.
They are not participating with men anymore until men kind of like,
get their stuff together,
fix these little flippies.
this reminded me of another creators video I saw a little while back
and it was like women who are in happy marriages,
if something happened to your husband,
would you get married again?
Overwhelmingly,
all of us say no.
Because there is an unspoken understanding amongst us
women who are married to men
who are very happily married and have like
wonderful partners,
that we are the exception,
not the rule. Like, I'm not dating men ever again, hopefully.
And knock on, you know something?
Thankfully I don't have to cause I found one and he's great.
But this also goes into the conversation of people who like.
Because marriage is such a societal standard,
people will tell you that it's awful,
but it's supposed to be awful.
No, like, you in fact don't have to do that.
I would rather, if something ever happened to my husband,
which god forbid, because he's my person,
um, I would rather be single for the rest of my life.
Or date women.
Than ever be in a bad relationship with a man ever again.
And I know lightning can strike twice. I know.
I'm just skeptical.